le gouvernement prépare sa rentrée et
elle s'annonce plutôt chargé réforme des
retraites ou encore la très controversée
réforme de l'assurance chômage les
syndicats restent vent debout contre
cette réforme jugée injuste alors que le
gouvernement n'attend que sa mise en
oeuvre les explications de mona où dès
lors
le gouvernement prépare sa rentrée
sociale sur fond de crise sanitaire et
de fin du quoi qu'il en coûte même si
matignon veut prendre avec prudence ce
virage et certaines réformes continue de
faire couler beaucoup d'encre notamment
l'assurance chômage porté par elisabeth
borde la ministre du travail une réforme
qui touchera près d'un million de
personnes en france mais pour le chef de
l'état c'est presque un texte déjà gagné
d'avancé j'ai demandé au gouvernement
dès cette rentrée de lancer un plan
massif de formation et de
requalification des chômeurs de longue
durée c'est pour cela que la réforme de
l'assurance chômage sera pleinement mis
en oeuvre dès le 1er octobre autour
d'une volonté simple en france on doit
toujours bien mieux gagner sa vie en
travaillant qu'en restant chez soi ce
qui n'est actuellement pas toujours le
cas mais ce texte traîne de lourdes
casseroles derrière lui après avoir
relevé plusieurs inégalités et les
syndicats ont déposé un recours contre
la réforme dès lors le conseil d'état a
décidé de suspendre un des pans de la
réforme qui concerne le nouveau mode de
calcul du salaire journalier et qui
permet lui de déterminer le montant de
l'allocation versée un demandeur
d'emploi de nombreuses incertitudes
subsistent quant à l'évolution de la
crise sanitaire et ses conséquences
économiques
ces nouvelles règles de calcul des
allocations chômage pénaliseront de
manière significative les salariés de
ces secteurs qui subissent plus qu'il ne
choisisse l'alternance entre périodes de
travail et période d'inactivité est la
rue de grenelle a donc soigné son
argumentaire cet été pour convaincre à
nouveau le conseil d'état d'autoriser
dans un mois le dernier volet de son
plan m et les partenaires sociaux
restent farouchement opposés à cette
réforme malgré elle et quelques
ajustements et philippe martinez de
secrétaire général de la cgt elle la
qualifie d'injuste cette réforme est
injuste car elle va pénaliser ceux qui
sont déjà dans une situation difficile
croire que c'est en tapant sur les
demandeurs d'emploi les plus précaires
qu'on va faire face aux difficultés
peut-être de recrutement c'est
complètement inconséquent la ministre
s'est rendu compte que dans cette
réforme injuste certaines personnes
étaient encore plus pénalisées que les
autres mais au delà des congés maternité
et des arrêts maladie c'est bien
l'ensemble de cette réforme que nous
contestons alors qu emmanuel macron
assuré que la réforme serait mise en
oeuvre dès le 1er octobre elle la
bataille est loin d'être gagnée pour
l'exécutif la réforme elle sera passée
au crible par les juges du conseil
d'état le gouvernement n'est donc pas à
l'abri d'un énième rebondissement